[Musique]
la dernière fois la dernière fois
et la portière [__] tu l'as des capots
sera en moins de deux non toi tu l'as
des cabots sera rappelle toi on tente et
on cause
ouais top police de miami blues fremm et
à saper encore qui ont compté mais
derrière la tête même toi je n'ai
dossier je vais pénétrer l'âme de cet
homme en tout ce à quoi bon sens de la
crème monsieur je sais que vous êtes
terrorisé c'est vrai tu l'appelles
maîtresse et profond tu crois j'en ai ma
claque mike je raccroche et voilà c'est
en partie jeu qu'on se souvienne de toi
comme du flingueur en tee shirt moulant
regardez moi ce foutoir
c'est un carnage était pas tout ça nous
avait descendu personnes
oui c'est vrai j'en ai descendu quelques
sa mère dans cette ville tu es le seul
en qui j'ai confiance
allez s'il te plaît mais pas de bruit la
dernière fois la dernière fois on est
pas de baignoire on est des flics aussi
on va ce coffret tout seuls comme des
grands
j'avais raison pour les lunettes ça fait
un an qu'elle se saoulent avec ça je
vois l'avions acheté les experts
bad boys band watching you wanna die
non plus jamais je veux plus jamais vous
entendre chanter ça ouais et vous
saloper les paroles il faut du temps
pour les apprendre président